one time oh so bad are we nervous to
play never have I ever
I saw you shaking a little bit I'm gonna
be I have not I have not indeed I don't
know why she thinks that I'm nervous
about him finding out my truth have you
ever been sexually attracted to a
cartoon character
[Music]
what cartoon character like Pocahontas
Princess Jasmine
hello have you guys seen Johnny Bravo
like he's a stud
I'm sorry I don't look like have you
ever lied about an excuse for being late
to one of our dates
oh yeah 104 oh my god what was it I say
that I like left work but then I don't
leave work you're gonna lie make it a
good lie how you ever posted a happy
picture of us when you were actually mad
at me probably the most recent one I did
not know that have you ever woken up
somewhere and didn't know where you were
I have many times have you ever created
a fake Instagram account
I have not what a surprise I've heard
this is a thing it's called a Finster
and people use it for stalking posting a
listed photos of them doing activities
or talking smack about other people this
is what the use they're doing now have
you ever popped the significant others
pimple for them very secretly like it
was a secret I don't even think she
knows this right above your eyebrow just
had been there like I've been there
excuse me have you ever sent a dirty
text to the wrong person and not just
one person just like the whole contacts
what is this story oh my god I was
trying to send her something sexy and I
accidentally sent it to my uncle once
did I ever receive it ultimately no why
did it stop it your uncle Chandra what
happened he actually
Spahn much better than I thought he
would he just laughed it off we never
spoke about it again have you ever had
sex in a public place yes lots of
everybody got to try it out you know I'm
pleading the fish have you ever been in
a Twitter or Facebook fight Oh oh my
gosh I hate people that do that
Raj is one of those people and I hate
him for it have you ever had a one-night
stand it just implies that I'm not I
didn't say that have you ever had a
crush on a significant others parent who
is this my mom no not your mom I think
you're not my god actually your dad's
attractive too he looks like you good
thing my dad can't use the Internet I
know this would go straight to his head
have you ever hooked up in another
family members bedroom the other point
there are some lines that I won't cross
you clearly don't have those boundaries
I did it when I was younger you know
have you ever been in love with your
teacher well not an academic teacher but
yes I have because there's permeant
woman is a teacher and she is educating
the youth of tomorrow and as a teacher
of life to my heart
[Laughter]
[Music]